I'll go get our drinks.
Thank you. That's very sweet of you.
Kathy? Hi! What are you doing here?
Susie? Hi, long time no see. How have you been?
I've been good. How about you?
Fine. Did you enjoy yourself during the summer holidays?
Yeah, I just came back from Venezuela. Are you with someone right now?
Actually, yes. Oh, here he comes. Susie, this is my friend Changmin.
Changmin, I'd like you to meet my best friend Susie.
She's an exchange student from Venezuela.
Hello, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too. You look familiar, though.
I think we are in the same computer class.
Yes. I think so, too. Sorry, I didn't recognize you at first.
Oh, that's all right. I have to go. My friend is waiting for me there.
I will see you around, Changmin.
Yes, it was nice meeting you.